am zweiten tag der belastungs übung wird
sich herausstellen wie gut die
teilnehmer unter stress das gelernte
umsetzen auch wenn heute kein maß an
steht heißt es noch lange nicht dass es
entspannter wird
uns platz in treff lingen oberösterreich
stellen sie sich verschiedenen
gefechtssituationen hier soll vor allem
die führungsfähigkeit überprüft werden
sehr guten neuen will sind hier am
übungsplatz treff link genauer in laage
bereich der zweiten klasse genannt
felsen höhe
das ist jetzt zehn minuten vor 55 uhr
sind dann die sogenannte morgen
bereitschaft in form von einem leisen
alarm
dazu wird leise alarmiert der leise
alarm.de grund um in die eigenen
stellungen nicht zu verraten
bereits nach der ersten nacht wird klar
viel schlaf wird es diese woche nicht
geben
zwei bis drei stunden müssen erst mal
reichen nichts für langschläfer das
aufholen weil ich ganz darin klar
relativ viel los im lager auch relativ
viele wachen weitere gefühl ist solle
kurzfristig ab deswegen wenig schlaf
gehabt
ich denke mir nur ich möchte nicht
brauchen aber nicht ans aufgeben hat bis
jetzt nicht gedacht gott sei dank es mit
liebe zahlen dort wird darum eine ziel
ist einfach wirklich die bloßen übung zu
schaffen und das auch schmerzfrei und
ohne weitere vorfälle absolvieren zu
können
die nächste darbietung und das böse auf
geschaffen und lasse mir gebracht zu
einer flieger stieg um mein ziel
das treibt mehr vorhaben warme diensten
gibt es nicht direkt nach dem frühstück
treten die gruppen kommandanten zur
ersten befehlsausgabe an mitbestimmung
in der klasse wurde der ausfall schon
verkraftet vergisst zweite gruppe ist es
ist fast als die welt gegeben
sie kennen ihre ladies den zustand an
western high maria dass sie krankheiten
wird das heißt sie wirken ihn auf die
kameraden das nicht so gut gestanden und
sich genau das sieht die große liebe
lässt sie wissen
ziel ist prächtig waren oft wie zu
marschieren verstanden
beginnen wir mit der befehlsausgabe für
seine freundlichen tag
sie dürfen nicht verwenden erste gefecht
situation für gruppe 2 12 bis die
bewegungs bahn
hier wird das absetzen und ermöglichen
zeitdruck geübt das szenario uno
mitarbeiter werden von rebellen
angegriffen und müssen sich zurückziehen
und damit es für die teilnehmer nicht so
einfach wird gibt es einen kleinen umweg
über ein hindernis
da ist teamarbeit gefragt auch ein
ausfall geübt die verwundete soldatin
muss mit einem berg transportiert werden
auch wenn es auf den ersten blick schwer
erscheint die zusätzliche last zu den
ohnehin 30 kilogramm marschgepäck die
jeder mit sich schleppt fordert den
teilnehmern einiges ab
doch wie viele wirkliche ausfälle gab es
denn bisher bei der bilanz umstellung
geben wollen vier ausfälle aus diversen
gründen von göttliche schöpfung bis hin
eben aus persönlichen gründen momentan
durch die privatsphäre respektieren muss
an dieser station wird das werfen eines
unterlegenen feindes geübt das heißt
ihre aufgabe ist es den gegner
zurückzudrängen
wie das erklärt der gruppen kommandant
seinem team
nachdem er sich ein bild von der lage
gemacht hat erschwerend kommt hinzu dass
sie das gelände überhaupt nicht kennen
einige stunden oder irgendwo hier geht
es neben der sicherung in stellung
das b team überreicht vor recht gut aber
zu langsam und nach unten etwas
unkoordiniert mehr koordinieren
mister bass mg wieder aufsteht die
nächste station der belastungs übung
nennt sich riegel
träger ist eine helix bezogene
verteidigung
in einem gelände gegen gegen
durchgebrochenen oder eingebrochenen
feind ein unerwartetes auftauchen des
übungsleiters baut zusätzlichen druck
auf er hinterfragt die gewählte stellen
hier wirken die 50 meter rechts die ihn
vielleicht ganz gut geht gut gewählte
stellung noch nicht sicherlich anders
als die schwerste wochen in der gruppe
kommen zu lassen
was soll der rover in geschützte so
einfach wirklich dafür liege definitiv
nicht der erste durchgang war natürlich
die handelsstufe die klassische der
zweite durchgang weil ich schon sehr
flüssig das heißt es hat von der
befehlsgebung her sehr gut geklappt und
es war einfach das was man sich
vorstellen in zukunft
ein extrem anstrengender tag geht zu
ende
der platz für das nachtlager ist endlich
erreicht während die einen mit dem
aufbau beginnen übernehmen anderer die
sicherung und langsam wird es dunkel
umgehen als gestern ist der rucksack
trotzdem überall mit also das merkt man
schon die müdigkeit merkt man also wenn
man umsetzen
das geht gar nicht aber soweit schon
gepasst
also wir schauen wollt dass man so gut
wie möglich alles erfüllen weil nix also
bis jetzt wo man doch alles nichts
verloren gezogen und hoffe dass das so
bleibt
sie können noch lachen heißt es ihm dann
gehts ja grundsätzlich meine einstellung
des abends war nicht zu gott geht das
immer noch schnell verbreitet habe
generell markt für die müdigkeit
das war alles ein bisserl träger
langsamer aber immer behalten dann steht
die motivation einer gruppe früher ein
bisschen durchhänger gehabt da war es
kalt und dunkel pons anpacken das ganze
also bislang spielt aber durch die
stationen nach frings neuester lebt
anstrengend natürlich aber nicht zum
ende des tages hoffen dass die nacht
ziemlich ruhig war
ob er sich da nicht schon zu früh freut
denn die ohnehin schon kurze nacht
könnte durch eine spontane verlegung des
nachts lagers noch kürzer werden
erholsam die nacht wirklich wird und
welche neuen aufgaben die gruppen
bewältigen müssen zeigen wir in folge 4